3 points
Today is the pollen I'm going to tell you again, the 7 secrets of studying that language
.  Please develop your attentiveness already
Fourth is
more than grammar 5th bread
5 Fifth is patient
Giraga Don't get frustrated and study Sixth is it?
It's a dinosaur I
have to buy a tool a
So when it comes to language study,
of course it's an mp3 player like this, isn't it?
There
weren't any mp3 players, right?
You can listen to those heel parts for dozens of hours, even in cities that have nothing left in the country
.
If it's interesting
content that I like, it's already January or February.
There are already various resources for studying online,
but even so,
when you're just starting out, it's still good to have an
introductory book or
something like grammar.  You can buy it
or borrow it from the library, but
you can also use the software internet that you need, such
as Kioka agents from various branches of the Impa Internet,
and dictionaries.
I don't have it before drinking, but
you can buy a dictionary for your iPad, but you can buy a dictionary for your iPad, right?
Well, it's better to buy something that you can pay for, so of course, even if all of that is added up, it's not a huge amount at the time, but it's still
necessary,
isn't
it?  In
many ways, studying will go smoothly.
I need a sixth secret like
Pussaro please